foreign
hey you guys it's Monday yeah we're back
once again with another haunting show
yeah this one you can see on YouTube but
you you have a hard time finding it
because they have it labeled strange
strangely and it
does remember they have it set up as
like a documentary not an episode well
it's because yeah it's because this one
was their first special right like
before this went to series
um they did two pilot episodes and this
was the first one of those the other one
was a haunting in Georgia about Mr Gordy
like we did a show about that case a
long time ago and I feel like we've
talked about this case too but it's
weird because man this episode I don't
even want to call it an episode because
it's like it's longer than a regular
episode it's like an hour and a half so
it's like movie length yeah um and it
was like a pilot so I don't know I'm
just assuming that they made these two
seeing if there was enough interest like
to do a series and then there was so
they went ahead and did it so they made
this
and you have to buy them separately like
from they don't come within the box sets
yeah with the with the series and this I
had a [ __ ] of a time finding this [ __ ]
because you can't stream it legally
anywhere I couldn't find it any place at
least in the United States uh nobody had
it so somebody uploaded it to YouTube
um and it's really shitty like the it
looks shitty but it sounds shitty yeah
yeah and it's it looks terrible but that
was like the only play and it took me
like forever to find it because you
remember the title I had to put in we'll
see the weird thing is that the title of
it is just like a haunting in
Connecticut yada yada but I had to put
in because I put in a haunting in
Connecticut 2002 because if you put in a
haunting in Connecticut it'll be all the
stuff about the 2009 movie which was
made like the fictional movie so I put
in 2002 and then I got it to come up on
my computer but I couldn't get it to
come up on the Xbox when I did the
search and in there and so then I
finally like put in a haunting in
Connecticut TV movie and then it came up
you know what I mean yeah it had like a
white
um
uh icon I think one with some with some
script something written on it
yeah I think it was like it was a shot
from the show which was like almost like
a drone shot of like snowy
like a snowy or like a cemetery or
something I couldn't really tell what it
is because like I said the it looked
like super super Shady so you can order
this on
DVD yeah I think you get it on I think
you can get it on DVD but it's not
streaming anywhere though does it come
with the Mr Gordy episode or are they
sold separately I think I saw I think
and please correct me if I'm wrong I
thought when I looked on Amazon earlier
I thought they sold a DVD or a Blu-ray
that had both of them on One Pilots okay
but it might be worth maybe not I don't
remember how much it was or anything
like that probably gonna use them for a
couple bucks I would imagine you can I
mean this is like like I said this is
really old this is like 2002. this is
like 20 years old at this point
here's the weird thing I remembered like
so much about this story
but when we started watching this
episode it occurred to me that what I
was remembering mostly was from the
Paranormal Witness episode
because on this episode this is really
weird
I mean I guess I can see it because like
I said this is 2002. on this episode
they did not use any of their real names
and they all like everybody all the real
people there on the show they all
appeared in Shadow but then like several
years later when they did a Paranormal
Witness episode they absolutely used
their own names and let their faces be
shown and stuff I kind of feel like I
don't know I think they didn't really
know this early on like what the
reaction would be and then after it was
like really positive like and successful
and then there's a book about it which
I'll get into in a little bit but then
they were like well hell we're gonna use
our real names and maybe we can cash in
on this [ __ ] well in 2002 the snedeker
case would have been long forgotten that
was something you saw on Heraldo when
you were a kid in [ __ ] 80s 86 85 you
know around that time well it happened
like the the stuff that happened to them
was 86 and I think the book that came
out I think was 92. okay because I
remember seeing that [ __ ] on Geraldo
when it was relatively new yeah this
snedeker case and a lot of the audience
was mocking them
but some some shows like he they would
go on uh what was it uh
Donahue I think some sometimes they take
that [ __ ] seriously I don't even
think Ricky Lake was out yet I think
that was late no she was around but but
the snatakers were hitting all the talk
shows
well yeah and each one was like a little
bit of a different reaction
and uh I guess that was I was I was out
out of high school so I guess it was 87
when I saw it
um on daytime television talk show
and um
I was kind of spooked I was buying it
for the most part after you know math
Mountain
what happened there I thought that maybe
like this is plausible
um seeing the seeing the original
Paranormal Witness and seeing this
episode
I thought there might have been
something to it
I'm not so sure now but yeah I actually
wrote about this case in my in my book
The Unseen hand and um
I don't really want to you know spoil
stuff right out of the game because this
is a good story I mean this is one of
the creepiest episodes yeah but I will
say that there has been
um a lot of speculation that this is
kind of like an AMD Ville kind of thing
but it might have been where they were
just fabricated from the very beginning
maybe yeah I remember there's a lot of
inconsistencies in the stories and
inconsistency in the in
inconsistency between the story that's
told to the public and then what the
original witness testimony was I
remember that there was a lot of that
kind of stuff like well wait a minute
hold on that's not exactly what that
witness said you know just like that the
early accounts differ from later
accounts that kind of yeah the story
gets bigger as it goes there's a lot of
I don't remember all the details because
you know like I said I hadn't really
researched it recently but I remembered
that the story kind of gets bigger the
older it gets
like Roswell story got bigger as it went
you know uh which that's a sign of
something becoming a legend
yeah I definitely do want to um kind of
get into that toward the end because
like I said we'll talk about the show
and like what the stuff but I do want to
kind of get into it too because Carmen
snedeker
um her stories have kind of heard the
details are inconsistent like over the
years like every because she's given a
[ __ ] kind of like some of the shit's
wild too like getting butt hooked
running down the street in public oh but
although they left that out the show
yeah they left that out they didn't even
mention that no in the episode but she
said she said that [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
daytime talk show back in the 80s I was
like what you gotta up your game if
you're a daytime talk show if you said
that on daytime talk show it had to be
true how funny would it be if she
actually used the term butt worked
yeah
so and my thinking of the time as as you
know teenager late teenager was that
um if the claim was wild [ __ ] like
that then it had to have been true how
could anybody make that up what are you
talking about I'm a horror writer I make
up crazy [ __ ] that was my thinking of
the time she said she was running down
the street getting raped by the ghosts
up in her ass
in public I'm not suggesting that rape
is funny but but that whole entire I was
like how can somebody make that up that
mental image is very very funny
invisible ghost invisible demons butt
working you while you're running
away
and I was like yeah that [ __ ] had to
happen man no woman would make that up
you know
that sounds like some [ __ ] I would make
up yeah like for a story they were
holding one girl down why it was goes
from molestinger and she said she could
see the hand and then the hand
underneath her clothes of her 90 [ __ ]
going up she could see the knuckles on
that head as it was grabbing her titty
basically that's what she said yeah and
that [ __ ] spooked me because I had
seen some [ __ ] at Mammoth Mountain some
Poltergeist activity
I'd never seen anything that looked like
a hand but you know moving objects and
things appearing and disappearing and
um kind of ghostly [ __ ] Force kind of
touch you you know well that was with
Lois and so I thought maybe this like
damn you know that that whatever they
saw that was a that was a strong one and
I could see this I could imagine that
something like that would be plausible
that it was so strong that
The Apparition of the hand underneath
the clothing you could see the knuckles
and the fingers on it I can imagine it I
don't think it happened but I can
imagine it I saw something kind of like
that just looked like a damn white
blur of I guess I don't know like a hand
like object
jump off the back of a dam rocking chair
and then just disvanish and
I don't know if it was a hand but just
think of some kind of force it was weird
it was so fast I couldn't make an image
out of it it was weird though it kind of
made it a connection with that and her
account of the hand underneath her
nighty [ __ ] going up
and it just creeped me out Danny Rowling
said didn't the niece get groped and
molested by the entity in the house yeah
that's what we were just talking about
but the thing about it is that they
didn't uh they didn't put that into the
haunting episode no I remembered that
but I remembered it because one I wrote
about this case and two uh they did
mention it on Paranormal Witness because
many years later
um I can't remember what year it was but
Paranormal Witness did this case too it
was season two episode seven and I think
it was called the real Haunting in
Connecticut so I'm assuming they put it
out sometime around 2009 like in
conjunction with the big Hollywood movie
that they made that was based on this
case so I remember that episode like a
lot more than this one this one was a
lot more restrained like in the stuff
they showed they didn't mention the butt
working they didn't mention uh you know
the the molestation really they just
kind of they kind of danced around it a
little bit but I mean I think the
Paranormal Witness episode was a lot
more overt although I think they also
left out the butt Hawking what I was
remember thinking at the time is I
thought it was the the son who was dying
to cancer
they moved him into this
Mortuary
and it caused a lot of damn internal
conflicts and I thought it had released
his his rspk or in other words they it
caused him to create a poltergeist and
his cousin was in there with him and she
was the one that was getting molested
and I thought maybe it might have been
some kind of subconscious incestible
desire for his cousin they were about
the same age well he did jump on her and
try to rape her right I think there was
a three-year difference I think he was
three years younger was he was younger
okay and uh that that the Poltergeist
was doing it too
tour but it was emanating from him you
know Poltergeist is not really a ghost
for you new listeners it's an artificial
ghost it's just psychic abilities
telekinesis
under the direction of the subconscious
mind and you think it's outside force
it's actually a part of you doing it
um and
it was trying to rape his cousin you
know [ __ ] and so it seemed very
plausible to me with having seen this
phenomenon before but there's a lot of
inconsistencies in the story
in the end I remember thinking that
it was artificial that they had based it
on stuff but it was I mean I hate to I
think it was I hate to like just call
out anybody for just like making stuff
up out of whole cloth but you have to
think too like the Warrens were involved
in this and you know how that kind of
[ __ ] goes right
um and like I said I kind of want to
talk about the guy that wrote the book
about it and what he said so I kind of
wanted I don't know what to tell you
toward the end I think my fine I haven't
looked at this case in a long time I
kind of remember
feeling or believing that my final
my final thoughts on it were that
something may have happened but it got
really exaggerated and possibly you know
yeah I kind of well that's what usually
happens I kind of feel like I mean if
you have I think this is very similar to
Amityville because Amityville was a
house where demonstrably something
horrible happened I mean defeo like
killed his whole family
um you know what I mean so
it's kind of the same thing here I mean
the house demonstrably did used to be a
funeral home yeah so maybe when they
moved in they were like you know hey uh
medical bills aren't cheap maybe we
should play this up and like do kind of
like you know I'm not saying that's what
happened I'm just saying that the the
pump is already primed because it's like
you know obviously like I said just like
the Amityville house obviously a
horrible multiple murder occurred there
so people are going to be more primed to
believe that maybe there's like some
Supernatural activity going on because
something horrible happened so same
thing here because the place used to be
a funeral home which everybody kind of
knew well I remember thinking that maybe
some kind of poltergeist
uh phenomenon had happened because of
the stress but that then that phenomena
wasn't good enough for the mass media so
they kept exaggerating it yeah and you
get more to make it stronger you know
what I mean more impressive some of that
stuff I think she just made up out of
whole cloth during those live television
shows that they were doing on daytime
television you know I didn't actually
they're live before the audience but I
think they're recorded yeah they are um
so some of that [ __ ] she'd run off at
the mouth Miss snedeker
and probably because she was trying to
fight the audience convince them that it
had really happened
and some of that stuff probably didn't
happen but I I think some things maybe
happen but they got buried underneath uh
a lot of exaggeration yeah I mean I'd be
willing to admit like maybe they moved
in and there was like some creepy [ __ ]
like doors opening by themselves or some
[ __ ] like that but his legs apparitions
and stuff and maybe but maybe it was
like really really minor yeah and maybe
things that kind of seemed like
possession because he was losing his
[ __ ] mind uh because he thought he
was dying and then uh maybe some ghostly
Poltergeist type phenomena with like
sexual intent [ __ ] cut going after
his cousin because he went after
if I remember correctly walked into her
bedroom jumped on top of her and tried
to have sex with her yeah in the middle
of the night
yeah I'm I'll get it he was under the
influence a bunch of drugs though too so
who knows
Sarah said in love with that shirt Jenny
thank you very much I've worn this
before I think we but yeah we made this
one I designed it and we printed it
um Zach said my thought is how would you
be able to [ __ ] anyone while running in
general and that just gives images of a
couple having a [ __ ] jog yes you're
running from this invisible force that
is uh repeatedly butt Hawking you
without any kind of lubricant or
anything and you're flying up into the
air with each thrust and and you can't
see it and [ __ ] everybody's look at
you like you're a [ __ ] because you
just went jumping and running and
they're trying to take [ __ ] pictures
of you and [ __ ] as this is happening and
nobody sees anything imagine that yeah
that would be that's and they couldn't
take pictures of you because they
weren't any cell phones back then laughs
October 8th said I'm gonna buy Jen's
books I didn't realize that Jen was an
author yeah I've written Lots oh yeah
she wrote a lot of books if you want to
read about this kind of stuff
get unseen hand it's real good yeah it's
kind of a compilation yeah I would say
we're three True Crime compilation books
and a bunch of fiction we never plug
books we never plug shirts we we don't
even [ __ ] make any money we just let
the [ __ ] run well I just like forget
about it we forget all about it and it's
like and I'm one of those kind of people
that is just like you know I write books
I do stuff like that and then I just
kind of put them out there and I'm just
kind of like hey if somebody wants to
read them that's cool I don't really
like and she's got audiobook too I'm not
like a I'm not a natural salesperson
yeah we forget all about audiobooks if
you guys like the show some of those
audiobooks are [ __ ] four hours long
huh but maybe even more some of them I
think unseen hand is available on
audiobook in it yeah Jenny reads it yeah
I did an audiobook version yeah the
recordings are pretty good yeah
the first few book we had re-recorded it
a couple times I think to try to get the
audio right so sometimes on her early
books you'll see some negative dings on
the audio quality that that got
corrected
yeah everything's updated I re-recorded
I think everything yeah
like you know
fairly recently or just yeah a couple
years ago yeah a good microphone we got
EQ and [ __ ] sound booth had all that
[ __ ] set up
yep that's right
all right so uh yeah Danny rolling also
said this episode was far superior to
the Hollywood BS film yeah I remember I
saw the movie but I don't um it was a
lot different
I remember it being okay but I don't
know I don't really remember that much
about it so it didn't really make an
impression Danny Rowling said did you
guys like this episode yeah I actually
do really like this episode it's just
weird because like I said I had
forgotten
I was thinking I remembered a lot about
this case but I was thinking of the
Paranormal Witness episode we'd seen
this before but we must have only seen
it once because when we were watching it
again I'm like I barely remember this I
said when I'm thinking about it I'm
remembering the Paranormal Witness
episode
do you hear what uh what was this a
galcomm he said he misses the
commercials yeah we have the commercials
uh recorded still we had yeah I got all
kind of I know well I never do it I know
I just forget it I forget I got lots of
commercials I got yeah we've been off of
our game really when it comes to selling
well it's a lot of stuff to keep track
of yeah and you know we need to we need
to start running our commercials and
plug it a little bit more because I bet
you sales would go up because they're
just kind of running on autopilot aren't
they
yeah essentially now I actually make a
couple more bucks off now on my um my
crime and Memorial videos I put uh I put
a commercial in that and I put um on my
scare salon videos I put
um commercials for some of my horror
novels and my games and stuff I made
commercials for that stuff so I do put
them in there but I just I forget
because to do them on the live stream
um you know I have to like put them over
here on this computer and I have to like
load them into the scenes and then like
sometimes we're just like having fun on
the show we're drinking and I just like
forget we need to get that [ __ ] loaded
up so we can just at the drop of a hat
you need to go use the restroom we'll
start playing commercials yeah I mean
that's what we used to do yeah we need
to get back on the game we've been lazy
Chang said the Warrens were involved
yeah that's all I need to know yeah
right
although look man the warrants were
involved in um
obliquely in in the [ __ ] Enfield case
and that's one of the best Poltergeist
cases I got the [ __ ] book on it in
here called this house was haunted and
that is really close to what we saw at
math mountain and now there is some
witness accounts in uh the infield case
that I don't think happened because
there's just so many damn Witnesses
chances are some people are going to
make some [ __ ] up but what newspaper
reporters and cops saw and the main
Witnesses uh
like guy guy lion play fair and
um uh what was his name uh Morris gross
even the girls themselves what they
reported I believe did happen all right
but what the cross crossing guard across
the street said she saw she said she saw
that girl float up through the I don't
know if she saw that for real you know
no one reported that except that
crossing guard uh although some a weird
thing did happen in that case
Janet said
that if she fell through the wall
and left her book on the other side
and in the in the other she was asleep
and fell through the wall I think is
what she said
and then came back
and she left her book over there and her
book was evidently in the apartment next
next door it had come from her room
but I don't know if that actually
happened in a poltergeist case objects
can do that they can kind of teleport I
don't know if she teleported over there
with the book in her hand or if the book
just teleported over there and she
dreamed that because she said she I
think she said she was asleep but it
happened
but that was a weird element of that of
that case
she had no way of getting in that other
apartment
you know
Jim key
but her book was over there
I don't know though I mean the Warrens
weren't really I don't I wouldn't call
them being involved in that case they
turned up on the doorstep one day they
claimed to have been involved then they
got kicked out off there like who are
you they didn't really know who they
were yeah yeah so but then they'd walk
around go yeah we were involved in that
case
even though originally
uh what was his name Warren what's the
guy's name uh
Ed Ed yeah Ed uh Ed said yeah we saw
that case there was nothing to it it was
a hoax
that's what he said but then later he
says oh no that was a fantastic case he
made a whole [ __ ] movie they tried to
[ __ ] weasel his ass into it yeah I
mean we've done two whole shows yeah
yeah once uh they just like I said
Lorraine always kind of seemed like a
nice lady and a True Believer but Ed
just seemed like a huckster
you know what I mean and uh that
actually comes into play in this case
yeah later on which we'll get into no
matter what you said you saw uh Ed was
gonna say it was a demon and he was
gonna [ __ ] encourage you to [ __ ]
um uh make the story more uh impressive
in other words lie
so they could write it up and go on a
lecture tour with it yeah
and they could like make themselves seem
more impressive but yeah and it was just
a definite pattern talking about
fighting these demons and trying demons
and fighting Medusa and [ __ ] fighting
anything you know but they're just
fighting werewolves he's killed a
werewolf or something I'm pretty sure
I'm kind of what I want to spend money
on it but they did write a book about a
werewolf I can't remember yeah it is so
I kind of want to read it though yeah
and then uh to collect everything in a
museum that you have to pay to see
everything
yeah yeah I don't know what happened to
that did zephas take that over I think
after yeah he's guarding all those
relics like Annabelle the doll and all
that kind of stuff the thing about it
they're [ __ ] I don't know like how
much money they get from like The
Conjuring Universal World obviously they
don't get any money now because they're
both dead but I'm just saying they're a
state I'm saying because of The
Conjuring Universe movies which are kind
of like based all on their [ __ ] like
it's a whole extended universe made out
of all their cases
and so I'd be curious as to like how
much they got paid for that [ __ ]
so I don't know I'm sure somebody knows
but I don't
um let's see October we said grift yeah
pretty much pretty much yeah like I said
so you want to get into this yeah all
right so as I mentioned this was the
pilot uh for a haunting so it was an
hour and a half just like a movie and
interestingly even though the snedekers
uh came were very public later on about
using their real names and their real
faces like I said they did a Paranormal
Witness episode right around 2009 2010.
they also were on Mysteries of the
museum
uh talking about the case but I don't
remember I like that show and I saw a
lot of episodes but I don't remember if
I saw that one or not but on this one
they didn't show their faces so they're
all in Shadow it was basically it was
Carmen
uh one of the sons uh who I think his
name was real name is Bradley although
they call him Bobby on the show and the
niece whose real name is Tammy but I
think they called her Teresa on the show
so I think it was just the three of them
right I think they were the only ones
that were the real people on there but
on the show they called them the main
couple Ed and Karen Parker but that's
not their names like I said it's it was
Al or Alan and Carmen snedeker
and uh yeah so that's kind of like I
don't know I don't know but like I said
they maybe they thought they could make
more money later on
uh I'll also note that I didn't even
realize until I was watching this for a
second time today was that this one
didn't have like the it still has
Anthony Collins the narrator but it
doesn't have that iconic theme music you
know what I mean because yeah all the
music's everything's different yeah it's
a lot different like it's not that
different like it's kind of like similar
to the later ones like I said it still
has the same narrator and stuff but it's
still like not the way uh the show would
eventually go
so um all right so here's the story and
at least this is what they showed on a
haunting and as I said I'll get into
like some more [ __ ] later because
different iterations of this have
different details this one's pretty
restrained as far as like some of the
crazier [ __ ] they said about later on
so uh they used fake names so I guess
I'm gonna use those two because that's
just what I used even though I know what
their real names are
who they call Karen Parker on here
and our oldest son Paul who was 14. now
this is in 1986 that this is happening
so he's been diagnosed with cancer it's
I think it's Hodgkin's lymphoma although
they didn't say that on the show
and the doctors have said that he
probably only has six months to live
unless he undergoes these super like
radical experimental treatments now at
this point the family were living in
Upstate New York but the treatments were
at this Hospital in Connecticut and it
was 300 miles away so basically they had
to do like an eight-hour drive I think
it was like eight hours round trip with
him yeah like every day
um you know so he could do the thing so
Karen was like well you know one I
couldn't like take care of the rest of
my family because you know I had three
other kids and blah blah blah or the
house or anything and um also these long
drives are really taking a toll on the
sun too because he was stuck in the car
for like eight hours a day and then he
had to go and do the treatment and all
that other kind of crap
So eventually the family decides well it
would probably be smarter to move closer
to the hospital so we don't feel like
[ __ ] drive eight hours every day so
Ed the dad whose real name is Al like I
said got his company to transfer him to
Connecticut and Karen started looking
for a place to live near the hospital
now she said that a lot of people
initially wouldn't rent to her because
she had four kids and that was kind of a
big thing in the um in the 80s because
as far as I know my parents had the same
kind of problem because they also had
four kids and yeah some apartment
complexes or some houses were like
absolutely not
um we don't want four children running
around even though we were we were
Angels but um but yeah so she was
running into problems
but finally she stumbles across a really
big house for a really really good price
I don't think she knew initially the the
way they show it on the show like she
just kind of I think they imply that she
saw like the for rent sign outside and
she went in and asked about it like I
don't think she knew
she because she was kind of like
desperate at this point because she was
getting turned down everywhere so she
saw the for rent sign she's like well
[ __ ] it I'll just like walk in there
even though I'm sure this is out of my
price range because
I don't know if I'm necessarily because
I know what the address of the house is
it's and it's very very easy to find if
you want to
uh you know on paranormal websites they
have like whole things about it uh but
there is somebody that lives there now
and has lived there for a very long time
so you know even all the Paranormal
sites are like please don't go and like
we know that it's famous now because of
like a haunting in Connecticut and
everything but it's like please don't go
and like take pictures of this lady's
house and [ __ ] like that it's a nice
looking house I gotta say it's kind of
like Colonial looking and it's really
really big because I looked it up on
Zillow after I figured out what the
address was and it's actually five
bedroom two bath and it's over 3 000
square feet and it's like 3084 square
feet or something so it's a big place
like when you see it and it's really
really nice
so like I said it's not I'm not
necessarily gonna say what the address
is but you can find it super easy I
found it in like two minutes and I found
pictures of the house and everything
like the real one
so she apparently sees the front sign
outside she goes in and she said the
inside was being renovated uh so there
was like a work crew but they let her in
to see it and she's like oh my God this
place is gorgeous and it's gigantic and
like I said they needed kind of a big
place because you know they have a whole
[ __ ] ton of kids and uh she's like so I
looked at it she's like there's no way
we're going to be able to afford this
[ __ ] because it's like massive but she
really loved it and she said it was like
only a couple minutes away from the
hospital
so um and she even went down in the
basement and looked and said oh this
would be perfect for like the boys
bedroom like the you know the one that
had cancer and like the younger brother
and she's like basically it seemed too
good to be true
now she brings Ed her husband to see it
and he also thinks it's amazing but then
when they go down to look at the
basement they see some [ __ ] that Karen
didn't see before now her story was I
don't think they said this on a haunting
but I know this because I looked it up
later
she said that when she first went down
to the basement she saw like the
basement part but because they were the
construction crew were there they were
like working on it and she said there
was a bunch of construction [ __ ] like in
front of this other door because there's
like another room like in the basement
and so she couldn't go in there or she
didn't see the door or whatever so she
didn't see it when she was in there
so when her and Ed come back to look at
it and she and he's like yeah man this
place is like really awesome but they go
down to the basement and then there's
like a room in the back that she hadn't
noticed before or hadn't looked into
before so they go in there and at first
they don't really know what they're
looking at they said there was like all
this stuff in there it was like a metal
Gurney there was like some bone saws
there's like the whole pump thingy that
has like the formaldehyde in it or
whatever and it's like At first they're
like what is all this [ __ ] and I'm just
like do you guys not like know anything
about like dead people or I don't know I
guess not but there's like
they weren't kids and one was a teenager
right no they I'm talking about the
adults Mom and Dad okay you're all right
I was thinking of the images in the
[ __ ] now program where they go down
there and they're playing in there yeah
okay yeah no that's they're not even
there yet okay I'm sitting there talking
about yeah there was even like a big
walk-in freezer down there and then
that's when Karen said oh [ __ ] that's a
morgue this is a this was a mortuary
um now I don't know if I want to say
this right now because that's another
that's one detail that has changed from
telling to telling like when Carmen
snedeker tells it because she likes to
say
in some interviews that she didn't know
that it was a mortuary until later like
after they had already paid like first
and last after they were already like
moving in and then she got like really
upset but then in other interviews that
I've seen or read with her she said oh
they knew and like the realtor came
forward and said no they absolutely knew
we told them ahead of time because
that's just kind of what you do she's
like the whole family knew like before
they moved in I remember also hearing
some stuff that was from the owner of
the of the of the the house
and he said that all the mortuary stuff
was gone
out of it
well see that was one weird thing about
it is that why
I can see leaving some of the stuff that
couldn't be moved like if there was a
big ass freezer or something like that
but why would you leave little [ __ ] like
bone saws and like a metal Gurney it's
like why would you leave that if you
were gonna rent it out it seems like
it'd be really easy to get rid of it a
lot of stuff came out over the years and
I remember that on one of these one of
these shows the guy that owned the place
was on one of those on one of those
daytime talk shows and he was saying no
no no no no but it's just all the stuff
that they're talking about all the
mortuary stuff was long gone the day
didn't Renovations and everything
that's what I'm saying why like it and
she said too that like when they moved
in they said they were working they
renovated all the inside yeah so it's
like why would they just leave all this
stuff in the basement it doesn't make
any sense no
I kind of believe that the owner of the
building that okay maybe it was a
mortuary that part checked out but there
it was the mortuary yeah so that checks
out uh but all this stuff about them
leaving bone saws and gurneys about
about it's yeah yeah see that doesn't
make sense because they were that it had
been renovated to be turned into a house
for rent right so they would have made
sure to get all that and that's
basically what the owner said he says no
none of that was in there
so it's it's not a sign that
the case is fake per se it's a sign that
they're exaggerating [ __ ] to make the
case [ __ ] sound scarier than it was
yeah because yeah that would be scary if
you moved into a house that you didn't
know was a funeral home and then went
down to the basement it's like oh my God
there's all this funeral home and [ __ ]
down here because but the owner was in
the audience of one of them and I think
it might have been Donahue and Donahue
[ __ ] stayed at the stood because yeah
yeah and he he stood up Donnie was
telling me because yeah I I own that
building he goes no because all that
stuff was gone
says you couldn't tell that it was a you
couldn't tell that it was a more yeah
why would you rent it out crap still in
there I think he had it said it had like
an elevator that was kind of like a dumb
waiter that you could move a body from
right downstairs to upstairs this is
that was there well yeah but that's
something you can't easily remove yeah
since that was there
um and
but I think I think you know that's been
a long time people okay but I think he
said that it had been sealed off so you
really couldn't
see it you know because it has doors
right that that have been kind of that
the elevator was there but it had been
covered up so you couldn't see that it
was there and I think maybe that there
was like a
a walk-in a like a walk-in refrigerator
yeah they did show that that it had a
walk-in-free yeah and at least at least
on the show they kind of showed it like
it was built in so like you could have
like a room but yeah so so I'm assuming
obviously they would leave that there
but
yeah others have like what yeah why
would you leave little [ __ ] like like
bone saws and you know the what what are
you talking about cats on his back she
said something
yeah she's laying there like this on her
back
yeah she said so a con I'm gonna go with
the owner of the building he was just
kind of smirking and shaking his head at
the at the snedeker's going you guys are
full of [ __ ] you know
well see that's what and like I said I
do like this episode and I like this
it's a cool story yeah I'm just saying
that that's my Spidey senses are
immediately just kind of like why would
they leave [ __ ] like that yeah in the
house if they were gonna rent it out to
somebody yeah the owner said they made
Extra Care to [ __ ]
try to kind of erase the fact that's
what I mean it's like obviously if I
owned the place and I said oh okay I'm
gonna rent this out to like regular
people it's like nobody wants to know
that [ __ ] used to like have all dead
bodies in it all the time yeah so you'd
want to like paint over everything and
like [ __ ] you'd want to get rid of
everything that said that you wouldn't
believe all that stuff in there
Ghostface is bringing up so that the the
the neighbor that lived across the
street at the snedekers was a [ __ ]
lookie Lou that would watch him with
binoculars and even write down [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the pan I remember her I
remember her inflicted the crowd turned
against her like who are you [ __ ]
watching these people and [ __ ]
writing it down is because she was
embarrassed but she was like trying to
uh that particular neighbor was doing
everything she could to try to uh make
the uh to debunk this case that's what
she's sure I kind of remember that yeah
yeah but yeah that it didn't happen that
they were lying
yeah and like I said I hate to like call
people out like and say that they're
making stuff up but some it's just some
of the stuff doesn't seem like all that
logical yeah but that neighbor [ __ ]
seemed like a whack job herself why did
she care so much well yeah that's that's
another thing like she's been like she
was [ __ ] crazy too yeah who would
[ __ ] do that I would like [ __ ] if
they were lying about oh cross the
street or not yeah they're lying across
the street I gotta stop this yeah it's
like what get up on me I mean get a
different hobby right you know what I
mean I don't give a [ __ ] lying across
the street that's what I mean I don't
give a [ __ ] what my neighbors are doing
unless it's like a serial killer or
something
no but if they're lying make it like a
[ __ ] ton of noise then other than that I
don't give a crap what they're doing
over there
so yeah
so uh yeah so they see all this stuff
and they're like oh my God this was a
mortuary and she gets really upset but
Ed is like well
you know it's fine it'll be fine like
nobody actually died in here there's
just I'm just like well it's a little
semantics there's two dead people you
just took dead there's just like Bin
Laden I had people in here it's like
nobody actually died here though like
that makes a difference I don't know but
um but yeah it's like obviously one
thing though what I've seen some news
reports on mortuaries in like uh funeral
homes
that were going out of business and
badly mismanaged that were [ __ ] one
of them was outside of [ __ ] Detroit
[ __ ] crazy there were dead bodies
unburied still in there and some of them
had been in there for [ __ ] yeah I've
heard about that uh hidden up in the dam
underneath the dam ceiling tiles were
[ __ ] big old shoe boxes of like 20
unburied babies that were just up in
there mummified
and
the guy who ran the place was just some
crackhead
who would take the body and if he never
really got payment on time he just
[ __ ] say [ __ ] it you know what I mean
he didn't he but when and then he
abandoned it and when they went in there
there were like [ __ ] 30 unburied
uncremated bodies still in there in
different stages
of decom composition and some of them
were had been embalmed and some of them
hadn't and it was just
man
[ __ ] bad
and uh the place had been abandoned for
like years before people went in there
and found all that [ __ ]
which is weird I guess because the
relatives were low income and they're
like oh well we didn't really pay for
any of this cremation or anything so
they didn't really care what happened to
the bodies they were just still in there
that shit's on YouTube you can find it I
couldn't imagine that though
what this place was not a place like
that though but it was just bad [ __ ]
can't happen in these [ __ ] places
I think the name of it originally I
think it was hallahan hallahan funeral
home something like that I looked it up
like when I was researching the book I
think it was hallahan yeah not a highly
regulated industry
surprisingly
nobody cares why is that surprising I'm
not surprised yeah they don't really
care what you do with these dead bodies
yeah it's like just don't leave them on
my lawn that's all yeah you know what I
mean stink up the place uh but yeah so
obviously that's why this house was so
cheap because it's like I said it's big
I looked it up on Zillow it's a big
house it's three over three thousand
square feet and five bedroom
so and they were getting it they didn't
say how much the rent was but they said
it was super cheap although I will note
the last time this sold and I'm assuming
that the same woman lives there now
um she bought it in 1998
and she bought it for 140 000 and it's a
massive and it's nice like I said I've
seen pictures of it but I I'm assuming
she still lives there or she still owns
it because it hasn't been bought since
1998 at least according to Zillow so she
either still lives there or she's
renting it out I don't really know to
somebody else
um because I was curious so I looked it
up
but so he said it was 60 feet this is
buried in the ceiling okay
yeah all right
uh let's see where was I okay
um all right so basically Karen's like
okay well I don't like living in what
used to be a funeral home but you know I
know we can't move we've already spent
all our money and otherwise the house is
perfect like it's right close to the
hospital it's big enough for everybody
yada yada so they agree that they're not
gonna tell the kids about it though
um Karen said especially if she didn't
want her son the one that had cancer
thinking about death all the time
especially because he's going through
all the treatments and everything but uh
there was also a cemetery like right I
don't know if it's right next to the
house but it was like really really
close to the house you know obvious
which makes sense
um so they figured well it's probably
going to be really hard to like hide the
houses pass from them and I'm assuming
that the neighbors probably new
that it was a funeral home too and I
kind of figure if the kids go to school
like somebody's gonna tell them so but
you know they didn't really want to tell
the kids now at this point the realtor
they said got rid of all the embalming
equipment I said you would think that
they would have done that before they
moved in but whatever uh some of the
larger stuff like the freezer and
everything got left like I said stuff
that they couldn't really move like I
said I don't know why they didn't move
it prior to them moving in but whatever
now the first thing that happens like
before they even brought their Furniture
in
at least according to Karen that's what
I'm calling her even their names Carmen
she was apparently mopping the kitchen
floor and the mop water turned like deep
red and thick she said like blood
and she's like mopping the floor and so
it looks like she's mopping blood
everywhere now said like first she
thought that she was like ruining the
floor something was wrong with the floor
like you know what I mean but yeah she
said it looked like blood and she said I
think her quote was it made my skin
crawl that's what she said so it's just
kind of like all this Blood like all
[ __ ] up
so at this point uh the sun I think I
heard somebody okay oh yeah I thought I
heard some at the door hold on one
second yeah we might have got packages I
got all my packages and [ __ ] like that
coming
so the sun uh goes down to the basement
for the first time because I think what
ended up happening was that the dad was
being transferred like because like I
said they were from upstate New York so
he had his company transfer him to
Connecticut but it was taking a while so
they didn't all move in at the same time
it's kind of like Carmen went first
um you know with one of the kit with the
kid that had cancer who were calling
Paul here
um but you know so they could go to his
appointments but the other kids and the
dad like were still back in the thing
and then they would come later and then
I think too that like the dad he didn't
um he had a thing where he still had to
work in Upstate New York like before the
transfer came through so he was like
only coming down on weekends like to say
for like a little while so they get into
that a little bit so uh the Sun
uh Paul goes down into the basement for
the first time which is going to be his
room like it's going to be his room and
his brother Bobby who's two years
younger who's 12 I guess
and he said when he first went down
there well he didn't say because he
wasn't on the show
um said that he felt like really icy
cold and also like somebody was watching
him from the room where all the
embalming stuff had been I don't know
what it looked like in real life but in
the show it was kind of like they had
this big space like the basement and
then there was like a there was like a
double door that had like glass panes in
it and then in there was like where all
the mortuary was in real life though I
don't think the basement was the
embalming room from everything that I
could determine because like I said I
wrote about this in my book and I did a
lot of research about it I thought from
what I could determine that the basement
had actually been the place where they
like the casket display room so I don't
think they were like doing embalming or
nothing like that in the basement unless
I unless I'm wrong but I think like the
room where they were where the two boys
were sleeping wasn't actually the
embalming room it was actually like just
where the caskets were displayed but I
could be totally wrong about that but
that was my understanding from
everything that I read about the layout
of the of the original
uh the layout of the original Funeral
Home
I went and got the mail too oh okay cat
treats
yeah
I got that chicken and they're throwing
oh okay
chicken thighs yeah that'll be good all
right yeah Danny Rowling said I think
the cancer came back and killed the sun
off in real life it did uh he died in
2012. I mean it did go into remission
like he did actually like grow up and
get married and have kids and stuff but
he it did come back and he died uh later
on so um so yeah so he goes down there
and he goes back upstairs and
he sees like the creaky door like the
basement door opens by itself and here's
somebody calling his name
so he immediately runs to his mom his
mom said he was scared to death and he's
like basically uh I don't like it here
we gotta leave now his mom is like well
maybe it's just because he's so close to
death himself because of the cancer that
he could like sense it was a funeral
home because they apparently hadn't told
him but she doesn't actually believe
that he heard an actual voice but just
in case she brings in uh the Catholic
priest that married her and her husband
and has him do some kind of like healing
thing voodoo on uh the Sun
now shortly after that the rest of the
kids move in now the other one of the
other Sons uh who they call Bobby like I
said I think his real name is Bradley if
I'm not mistaken he was two years
younger
so he was 12. and the two of them are
really close now this guy actually is
the real guy is on the show like in
Shadow he's the only one of the snedeker
kids that came onto this show
um although the niece actually does show
up later on so the two of them are going
to be sharing the basement room now Paul
uh the you know the older son has found
out about the funeral home situation
somehow like I said you know it seemed
like it wasn't really a big secret or
anything and he told the younger son all
about it even though the parents told
him not to uh so he said that the first
thing was that you know he would kind of
like tease him about it and he even like
made him get up on the morg gurney like
without telling him what it was and like
spun him around on it and [ __ ] like that
um and he said that was like really
creepy and like scared him really bad
like once he found out what it was right
even though again it seems like the
realtor said they took out all the stuff
like after why would the more Gurney
still be in there why would why would
you leave that for the family either
they're not gonna need a more Gurney I
would hope you're the owner and landlord
said all that stuff is gone I said yeah
and like I said that makes more sense to
me that makes more sense to me
so Karen and the kids are in the house
largely on their own for a while until
as I mentioned Ed's transfer came
through so he would only be there on the
weekends now one day uh the their one
daughter who they call Connie on the
show I'm not entirely sure I don't
remember what her real name is but um
she seemed kind of little she was moving
like seven or something like that and
she apparently saw a woman in her room
looking at her and ran to tell her mom
about it so Karen says she was actually
trembling when she told her about it and
Karen said this was really unusual
because you know this wasn't a kid that
was like real skittish or scared of
everything so the fact that she was like
freaking out so much you know was like
really unusual so Karen obviously goes
to the room and obviously doesn't see
anything
now Karen figures she's like well it
must have been that Paul the oldest son
told all the other kids that the place
was a funeral home and now they're like
[ __ ] with the daughter like they're
playing tricks on her and like trying to
scare her you know what I mean daughter
again I'm not sure she looked in the
show the actress looked like she was
about sevenish okay she was she looked
like she was the youngest okay
um you know what I mean I'm I can't
remember I think maybe she was seven or
eight if I'm remembering correctly
um but yeah so Karen accuses the boys of
like you know we please stop playing
tricks on your sister and they insist
that they didn't tell her that it was a
funeral home and they weren't playing
tricks on her or anything
now meanwhile in the basement the two
boys are seeing what at first appears to
be somebody moving around behind the
door to the other room because remember
how I said that it was like a double
door with like glass panes and they said
at first they were like they would lay
there in bed and look at it like in the
dark and they thought it was just like
Shadows from outside or something but
they said the more that he looked at it
looked like a person like walking around
in there and it was like freaking him
out and so they started like not wanting
to sleep in the basement anymore so they
would go up and like camp out in the
living room
and basically their mom came down it's
like what the [ __ ] are you kids to like
do in a living room and they said uh
there's a guy in the basement and she's
like yeah whatever [ __ ] I was like
there really was a guy in the basement
we'll make him pay rent or something
like that like she didn't believe like
anything they said she thought that they
were all just like full of [ __ ] uh both
the brothers insisted that they saw the
person though and he was like moving
around behind the door
now Karen was kind of hoping that all of
this nonsense would end once Ed arrived
there for the weekend uh but while like
before he got there though like she
asked the one of the other kids Bobby to
go down to the basement freezer to bring
up some bread because they had a bunch
of stuff down in the freezer which
I guess that had bodies in it and they
were like okay we're using that to put
food in I mean I'm sure they cleaned it
but but still okay so uh the kid didn't
want to go down there because he was
like wigged out but he's so he goes down
there kind of reluctantly
meanwhile while he's kind of creeping
around down the basement Karen and she
said this happened more than once like I
think they only showed it once on the
show but I think like when I read some
stuff about it later she said that it
happened more than once Karen sets the
table for breakfast and then she goes to
take like get some [ __ ] out of the oven
or whatever and then when she turns
around like back to the dining room the
table isn't set and the dishes are back
in the cupboard
she said that that was like pretty
common that that happened a lot and she
was like I just thought I was going
crazy she was like I know that I set
that table and you know and and then I
turned around and the dishes weren't
anywhere
so Bobby is down in the old morgue and
apparently hears a voice calling his
brother's name uh he called it on the
show the real guy he said it he called
it a deep grimy voice
and then he just had his hand like on
the door of the freezer and then uh he
hears that and he just like nopes the
[ __ ] out he's like nope so Karen goes
down with him to get the bread and of
course she doesn't see or hear anything
now Karen still doesn't believe the kids
thinking it's just their imaginations
um Bobby said that him and his older
brother it's like we always knew the
house was haunted from the time that we
moved in we never thought we were crazy
we always knew there was something in
there
um so
we just kind of like kept it to
ourselves though uh after a while Karen
also said she started like teasing Bobby
about the boys like ooh like it was so
scary and [ __ ] like that like so she
said she felt bad later on but you know
what I mean so at breakfast like Ed
finally gets there for the weekend and
Karen and Ed finally break down and
admit to all the kids that the house
used to be a funeral home now at this
point Paul tells his dad about the man
in the basement and Bobby like backs him
up on it yeah there's really a guy like
walking around in there but Ed of course
doesn't believe them either and he says
to Paul hey you're the oldest and you
need to like set a good example and stop
telling the other kids ghost stories
because you're scaring them and it's
like you know you're making their
imaginations run wild or whatever
Bobby also said that Paul had changed a
lot after the cancer diagnosis which I
mean you know that stands to reason he's
a 14 year old kid uh he's maybe dying of
cancer and so he's not gonna be like a
bundle of joy you know what I mean or
like be like super cheerful I get that
um but there was also a lot of stress in
the family too just because of how much
money it was costing uh so that was like
taking a toll also now Karen and Ed at
this point they still kind of think
maybe that Paul be like seeing things
maybe that's like a side effect of his
medication or maybe his mental health is
deteriorating like in light of his
cancer diagnosis which like I said
wouldn't be all that surprising
but the thing about it though is that
Karen also noticed some weird [ __ ]
happening in the house also one of the
minor things that she noticed was all
the crucifixes would disappear from the
walls uh and she would never be able to
find them like they would disappear like
one by one so there was a bunch of
crucifixes like all over this because
like I said it used to be a funeral home
so there'd be like over the doors and
whatnot and I think they showed this
more in Paranormal Witness like they
lean more into this
um they just mentioned it on here a
couple times but she said like you know
there'd be one like on the back of a
door or something then suddenly she'd be
walking through and be like hey where
the [ __ ] did that go and then like it's
not there anymore you know what I mean
so after a while
um the boys in the basement started
seeing even more apparitions Bobby
described it as four guys in dark
clothes and they were like whispering to
one another and says that he says that
he saw them like picking things up and
like looking through papers like they
were in the corner of the basement room
like around a table or something
the first time that they saw this uh
they ran upstairs and woke up their
parents but of course like when the
parents came down there was nobody there
Ed goes all around the house checking
the doors and the windows he even goes
outside and he's like there's no way
nobody could have gotten in like it was
snowing outside there were no footprints
in the snow it's like there can't be
anybody in here
um and at this point their dad is like
getting super pissed off and he's just
like losing his patience because like
you [ __ ] keep waking me up in the
middle of the [ __ ] night and you know
and I come down here and there's nothing
in there
and the kids are gonna kind of get more
and more upset that they aren't believed
and the boys start sleeping with all the
lights on and they said that we would
tell the other two siblings like what
happened too because Connie also saw
some [ __ ] I think the other kid that
they called Mark in this I don't think
he ever saw anything but the other three
did and um but they so they would like
tell each other all the time just so
they would know that they weren't crazy
like that there was other people they
could talk to about it
so Karen actually asks Paul's oncologist
like at his next appointment if his
medications could be causing
hallucinations but the doctor said no
that's not one of the side effects so
then Karen thinks that maybe Paul is
having mental health problems on top of
the cancer which you know is a little
bit alarming because the family is
already up to their eyeballs in medical
bills
and along those lines they get an
electric bill and the dad sees it and he
is like really pissed off because he's
like this electric bill is ridiculously
high and he attributes it to the boys
keeping their [ __ ] lights all the
lights on in the basement like all the
time because they're scared
so he goes down to the base even though
to me it seems like just having a few
lights on like light because light bulbs
don't really use all that much
power you know what I mean yeah so I
kind of feel like that's not what's
making your electric bill that high dude
I'm like maybe you should check like
your fridge or your other wiring or some
[ __ ] like that because if there was a
problem or your heating bill yeah it's
not light bulbs I'm telling you right
now notice that that was kind of a
common complaint about these uh haunted
house type deals is that
you know what I mean the power is
getting sucked up mysteriously yeah I
always kind of think that maybe there
might have been some copycat type
situation every now and then in these
stories yeah you know what I mean like
because it seems to kind of come and go
like that was like that was like an 80s
thing yeah and no matter what we did you
know what I mean the power bill was
going crazy yeah
so maybe it was that but it's just like
that that was another thing too that
really didn't that kind of like I know
it was like a minor thing but why would
you think if the if the electric bill
was indeed like way way higher than
usual I would not jump to attributing
that to oh my sons are keeping like a
couple extra light bulbs burning all
night that would absolutely not make
your electric bill go up that much right
I mean that's not that's not back then
no that's not one of the main appliances
that causes like your electric bill to
be high like I said you want to look
more at like your air conditioning
heating system your refrigerator like
your big appliances little light bulbs
aren't going to do it yeah and in the
80s power was cheap right yeah I was
kind of like wondering because they
showed well they actually on the show
they showed the electric bill and it
said it was like 386 or something like
that and I said that's yeah that's about
right for a house that size I would
think but I mean not in the 80s but
nowadays nowadays that's that's about
right yeah because that house I don't
know what state you're in well that
house was about the same same size as
this one you know what I mean like more
or less and that's usually that's about
right right yeah that's that's about
what our electric bill is so running two
two central air conditioners and if
that's running two central air
conditioners but I mean back in 1986
that was a lot I got it
um but yeah
so basically uh he thinks oh the
electric bill it's like you [ __ ]
running the lights all the time so he
goes down to the basement and takes out
all of the light bulbs like of the
overhead lights he just leaves them like
one little lamp like on their bedside
table and they're just like no because
like I said they were so scared and
everything so he goes in there and takes
all the bulbs out now that night it
seems like uh they're sleeping and
they're kind of freaking out because
there's only one light and they hear the
door creaking and then they hear a girl
giggling
and then their overhead lights start
going off and on even though there
aren't any bulbs in there oh yeah which
they really which they were like weirded
out but they're like what the [ __ ]
they're like pretty like Dad came down
here and took all the bulbs out yeah so
then they look over and they see their
sister Connie standing on the basement
stairs flipping the light switch up and
down like turning light on turn the
light off turn the light on
um and then they're like what they're
like looking over there and then Connie
then turns around and runs up the stairs
so Bobby like runs after her but when he
gets up there his parents who are still
up they say Connie's been upstairs in
bed for hours and she hasn't come by
here like we haven't seen her we would
have seen her like come by the baits to
go down the basement so Bobby goes
upstairs and sees Connie Oh indeed sound
asleep in her bed so Bobby's like
freaked out thinking oh well this this
evil entity or whatever it is in the
house is now like impersonating members
of my family so that's like a little
alarming that it can do that right that
was this that was actually my favorite
scene I think just because how freaky
would it be like to one like the lights
are coming on and there's no bulbs and
then you look over and see like a family
member just sitting there going
like that and then like you turn and
then they're like not there that would
be like really really freaky
so um at this point uh Paul has stopped
bothering talking to his parents since
they never believe him anything he says
he decides that he's going to confront
the voice that keeps calling him which
is never a good idea in these episodes
so he goes back into the morgue room and
the program shows like a guy with black
eyes like in a suit like looking evely
at Paul which I'm guessing is the
manifestation of the demon or whatever
now apparently this is akin to what he
saw because he did call it in real life
the man in the suit so that's what he
called it so that's what they showed it
as now after that uh Paul starts turning
into a teenager meaning he starts like
listening to like blasting loud rock
music wearing black becoming more quiet
and reserved pulling away from his
family [ __ ] like that which like I said
is not all that weird but whatever
he also insisted that he needed his own
room man uh so Bobby has to move out the
basement and he says that him and uh his
brother who had been very very close
prior to this time uh kind of became
alienated after that as he got like all
brooding and teenagery like I said I
started drawing weird pictures yeah he
started and and doing like uh writing
poems about necrophilia and [ __ ] yeah I
remember uh
and one of the programs I think they
showed the actual things that he was
drawn it was pretty good or at least
supposedly it was what he was actually
drawn yeah but I wasn't in any of these
documentaries I think it was on one of
those talk shows
that they showed yeah I don't I kind of
vaguely remember them but yeah it was
pretty weird yeah
so Paul's cancer actually goes into
remission soon after that and it seemed
like they didn't really Hammer this home
too hard but I think they were trying to
draw a parallel between his mental
health or his demonic kind of [ __ ] like
taken over but then like his physical
health getting better
because they said his cancer went into
remission after that
um but he was just kind of like yeah
whatever you know what I mean he was
very he was very teenager about it now
not too long after this Karen actually
invites uh her 17 year old niece Teresa
that's what they called her on the show
her real name is actually Tammy
um to stay with them while her parents
are going through a divorce now when
Teresa gets there like everybody's all
super jazzed to see her but Paul stays
in the basement now she said that her
and Paul had always been really good
friends so she was kind of like you know
why isn't he up here to see me and but
Karen was kind of hoping that having her
around would like help bring him back to
normal
so Teresa goes down to the basement to
see him but she said that she
immediately noticed the difference in
him she said he looked uh he sounded
angry and like he was getting mean and
he told her about like seeing and
hearing things and saying that his
parents didn't believe him he said
things were getting worse and he felt
really isolated and alone and he said
whatever this thing was was always
talking to him and wouldn't ever leave
him alone and it told him to do bad
things to his family because his family
sucked and hated him and like deserved
to get killed or whatever so Teresa said
that he had these really weird look in
his eyes it was like unlike him so she
kind of like thought he was possessed I
guess uh Teresa also said when she moved
into the house I was like kind of poor
it's a poor girl because it's like she
moves out her regular house because her
parents were going through a divorce and
were like screaming at each other all
the time and then she's like moved into
this house and now these people are
screaming at each other all the time
she's like I'm just gonna go sleep in a
car or like in a bus station I'm sure
and be like much quieter but yeah so so
there's that but yeah they said the
family was fighting all the time because
Paul was like acting out of control uh
she said too that Paul got to a point
where he wouldn't even leave the
basement because according to him I
guess like the demon was constantly
telling him to go upstairs and do [ __ ]
to his family so he was either choosing
to stay down there so he wouldn't kill
them or the demon was making him stay
down there I'm not really sure uh which
of those two things is the case
so Teresa then she feels kind of bad
about going behind Paul's back and like
knocking on him essentially but she's
like she was really worried about him so
she goes to the mom and tells the mom
about all the stuff that Paul said and
said she said well he feels like this is
a demon like the man in the suit and
it's like controlling him
now Karen again is not really believing
the [ __ ] and said well maybe it's just
because of the cancer he became like
obsessed with death and all this morbid
stuff or whatever
and Paul had also said I guess that the
demon threatened to do things to him if
he didn't do what he was told and he
said that he saw like dead people in the
basement all the time [ __ ] like that now
he also at one point like he started to
kind of get violent toward Teresa he was
trying to spin her around in the gurney
kind of like you know pushing her around
and stuff and chased her up the basement
stairs and then she said after that she
didn't really trust him anymore
um and the other kids were scared of him
also because they said that he got real
unpredictable and you know he would just
like get mad at the drop of a hat and
like you never really knew what he was
gonna do so everybody just kind of like
avoided him because you know like I said
he was kind of scary
uh so at this point Teresa starts
wearing these rosary beads that Karen
gave her like for protection or whatever
which kind of factors into the plot
later on
so at this point
um you know Karen decides she's going to
take Paul to a psychiatrist who was very
concerned about his behavior and
suggested further therapy uh Karen
agreed to this but seemed the show said
it was already too late in real life he
was actually
um diagnosed with schizophrenia but uh
they did not mention that on the show uh
but that I found that out later on
now soon after this
Paul goes into Teresa's room in the
middle of the night and basically I
stood at the end and was like pulling
the covers off her and then he jumped on
top of her and it looked as though he
was like trying to rape her they didn't
say that on the show but that's pretty
clearly what they were implying
um so basically uh Bobby the other
brother was like yeah he just went
totally off the deep end he was like
getting really violent so at this point
like Karen calls an ambulance and they
came and took Paul away they like they
put him in a hospital like I said he was
diagnosed with schizophrenia later on uh
so they said that he was like crying
when they took him away like asking
where are you taking me like blah blah
blah as they were taking him away at
least according to the mom Paul said to
his parents well now that I'm out of the
house they'll be after you that's what
he said so it seemed to be like he was
warning them that like oh all the demons
are gonna like get after you now because
I'm you know I'm not here anymore
uh so at this point Karen is still not
believing that there is any nefarious
[ __ ] going on this house and is
convinced that Paul has completely lost
his mind and will probably never be
normal again so he essentially gets
committed uh you know what I mean he
gets uh yeah he gets put in the hospital
in real life I don't know they like I
said the timelines on these are kind of
like squirrely they never really tell
you he was in there for like a month and
a half I think like he could you know
and like I said they did diagnose him
with schizophrenia at least as far as I
could determine so there's that now uh
so when Ed and Karen got home
Karen goes to drop the keys in this
remember how I said like they had like
the crucifixes and [ __ ] like that like
all over the doors and everything they
had like by the door there was this
little I don't know I'm not a churchy
person so I don't know what the [ __ ]
little baptismal font kind of situation
that had like a the holy crucifix ever
that had like a little did you like dip
your fingers in it or whatever yeah yeah
okay well they had one of those in the
house and she had been like putting her
keys in it I guess yeah and so she comes
in and goes in there to dissolve yeah to
watch well no there was no water in it
but it's like it used to have water in
it so um so she goes in there dropped
the keys and she noticed it's gone it's
just completely like disappeared off the
wall uh so she's like okay that was
weird and like it wasn't on the floor or
nothing they never did find it
apparently and what yeah I grabbed her
feet she's like don't touch my feet
daddy you know better like me touching
her feet well yeah most cats don't
surprise you attention to feet yeah
she's like she's like I'm gonna bite you
[ __ ] don't you she is she will bite you
yeah eventually she doesn't bite hard
though yeah she knows she doesn't want
to hurt you just it's a warning
um but yeah so she tries to tell Ed
she's like uh hey bro like the thing is
gone from the wall where he usually put
the keys isn't that weird and he's just
like I don't know I don't want to hear
about it you know what I mean
because our son just got committed and
whatnot
now uh so basically at this point it had
been like a long night I guess it's like
four or five in the morning and uh Ed is
just kind of like he has to go to work
and he has to leave for work not too
long after that now meanwhile Karen uh
she's still at home and she goes down to
the basement to sit because she's
wondering now hey maybe Paul wasn't
crazy after all I'm like well it's a
little late to be thinking that now now
that you haven't committed so she goes
down to the basement sits on the steps
and she's like waiting for something to
happen she said she was hoping that she
would see something so it would be like
definitive that her son wasn't crazy and
she said it was really cold down there
like freezing cold and she said she felt
fearful but she didn't really see
anything as much as she wanted to she
basically like dared the thing to show
itself whatever it was but nothing
happened so she was kind of like
ambivalent about it also at home
uh Teresa is asleep and her rosary beads
like pick themselves up kinda and like
they start moving around her neck like
that and then Karen goes meanwhile she
goes in the shower likes to take a
shower they showed this on Paranormal
Witness too and then like I get the
shower curtain like pulls tight around
her like it's gonna suffocate her and
she can't get out you know so they
showed that so she's like screaming and
[ __ ] and then Teresa also has the covers
pulled off her and she hears her aunt
screaming so she runs in there and helps
her and they have to like pull it or
like cut her out of the out of the shed
or whatever and then at this point they
realize oh maybe there is something evil
in the house after all this must have
been where they left out the part where
the go the the the supernatural force
was molest in the I think they did
include that in the Paranormal Witness
one yeah but it wasn't really on here
all they showed on here was her rosary
beads like being picked up off her neck
and then it showed like the covers
coming off
by themselves
[Music]
the daytime talk shows what was
described probably around this time or
at least this time or sometime after
she ran in what was the Miss netica ran
in to see the niece
in bed
and she saw a [ __ ] hand
an invisible hand underneath her blouse
there was a nice shirt or something go
up she could see the knuckles on it and
it was grabbing her around the breast
and stuff and she started trying to
fight with it and hold her down but
there was no way she could protect her
from it that
she could see Hands [ __ ] underneath
the dam her clothes
it's creepy story from what she said you
know she and the girl tried to roll over
and protect herself from it and the
[ __ ] hand thing would just vanish and
come back somewhere else
and I think she said she saw it come out
and then move across space but vanish
that'd be weird just a disembodied hand
yeah I think I remember them saying that
moved a few feet and just faded away
which that that was kind of a weird
description of yeah they didn't maybe
could have happened they didn't uh
mention that on this yeah like I said
basically all they said was like the
covers being pulled off
and the rosary beads like being picked
up and stuff
so they I maybe they were trying to go
from like a more family friendly Vibe so
they didn't really want to like do any
of the more sexual stuff on the show
from what I remember she said it was
just kind of a disembodied hand
she could see the wrist and it was just
kind of a bony Caucasian hand
that went down past the wrist a few
inches and just kind of you know what I
mean that but it was moving fast she
couldn't see it real clearly
yeah but she said when it was underneath
the clothes she could see the
impression of the knuckles and the
fingers and stuff going underneath her
down grew up there and grab some of that
titty meat
titty me titty me that's the 17 year old
girl you're talking about I know don't
be creepy well I got Teddy meat
a thousand pounds of it but uh no it's
just weird
is that spooky
and because of you know my experience at
Mount Mountain
[ __ ] with that Poltergeist this
sounded plausible I didn't see anything
like that I saw others I saw stuff like
that but not that but and it I could
imagine that the Poltergeist that I saw
could could replicate that I don't know
where they got that maybe she did see
that I don't know but they cut it out
they cut it out of other stories they
didn't want either that or they hadn't
established that detail of the story yet
like maybe they didn't add that detail
until later no I heard that early on
while it was still in the 80s yeah early
on so maybe that maybe admitted later
maybe the makers of a haunting were like
yeah we don't want to put too much of
the sexual stuff in there because no she
was underage maybe they were afraid of
talk about that I don't know yeah it
might have been that too because like I
said they didn't do any of the any of
the Ghost Butt working either right they
didn't talk about anything
I think that happened to the to miss
netteker I think and the dad too I think
I think that happened to the dad and I
think it happened to the niece well so
they said
allegedly ghost going anal man on men
and women
well you know that's right all right
that's the dad the dad also said that
yeah that's some weird well then I did
they get that from the small case
because I kind of feel like the same now
this moral case that was the one with
the pigs right with the pig people I
don't remember that's been so long I
don't remember that I kind of feel like
we should do a show about this moral
haunting at some point like if I put it
in the poll a couple times I can't
believe we haven't done one maybe we
didn't I just don't remember we've done
so many [ __ ] shows I can't even
remember what [ __ ] [ __ ] we talked
about when we haven't uh but yeah so
meanwhile uh Ed the dad
is at work uh and he's in his office and
his truck apparently starts itself up
and drives through his office
this seems like it would be something
that would be like fairly easy to check
because that's like a big ax that's like
a big deal but it's like I don't so I
don't know if that really happened or
not but he said that the the truck
started up and drove through his office
so while this is going on at his work
wherever that is
um back at the house the phone rings and
then Karen picks it up and then she
hears a girl giggling
and so then Karen and Teresa are sitting
at the kitchen table freaking out
because like I said you know uh Teresa
just had you know her covers pulled off
and Carmen all this like Carmen Karen
whoever uh got her you know thing with
the shower curtain so they're sitting
there freaking out and then they see
they said they saw some black
I'm not really sure how she described it
it was like a black shape Teresa said it
that it was like a man floating up near
the ceiling like a black like a shadow
figure like on the ceiling I guess yeah
they didn't describe it real well
and then see this might be referring to
a part that they took out because they
were talking about the man floating up
by the ceiling and then they'd have
Teresa on there the real girl and she
said it felt like a thousand hands all
over you and I'm like that doesn't sound
like a man floating up by the ceiling
that sounds like some ghost molestation
so maybe they did have that scene and
then they had her talking about that but
then they took that out because I was
like that's a weird thing for her to say
because that's not like related to what
they were talking about but that's maybe
yeah you know it's kind of frustrating
because now you have the television
programs interfering with the damn
witness testimony so you in which the
haunting unfortunately does that a lot
yeah they interfere with the witness
testimony for I don't know censorship
reasons
I'd rather know exactly what the
witnesses said
and the timeline of how the story had
changed
but we'll see
yeah because I mean a lot of times these
cases because when we've done episodes
before a lot of times unless the case is
really famous like this one you can't
really find a lot of other like outside
information yeah about the [ __ ] you know
and then if you were going through the
old talk shows you'd have to find the
old talk shows you had to put them in
order
and then you'd have to just
hope that this that there's enough in
the story to make a timeline because I
remember miss snedeker when the [ __ ]
audiences start [ __ ] with her she'd
just come up with some crazy [ __ ] that
you had never heard before about the
case yeah to try to back up what she was
saying
so you don't know when that when that
was added to the story because you only
have recordings you know what I mean you
don't know her you weren't hanging out
with her you know how the story had
evolved or not so you don't know
but it's just that's the problem with a
lot of these cases that you you know
that you don't witness yourself you're
dependent on witness testimony and
sometimes people are in the way of the
witness testimony
so it's a problem
Danny Rowling said insert where is that
raccoon sound effect okay maybe maybe
there you go
all the trouble to make that but it's
like I just keep [ __ ] forgetting uh
but yeah so they said so yeah they said
they saw something with some kind of
Blackness or some kind of like Shadow
shape or something like that like up by
the ceiling then Teresa's Rosary lifts
itself lifts itself up and like breaks
it's like all the beads go flying
everywhere
then the phone rings again but this time
it's Ed telling her holy [ __ ] the truck
just started and drove right through my
office it looked like a construction
site so it was like one of those little
offices that's kind of like you know
just a little prefab type of thing so it
drove through there he wasn't hurt or
anything but it just seemed kind of
weird so at this point they now suspect
The Entity is real um no duh and can
follow them wherever they go because
they figure hey if it followed Ed to
work then it can go anywhere if they
move or whatever so at this point
they're like okay well we gotta call the
priest
now before the priest gets there Bobby
said he was sleeping in the living room
and he thought he heard Paul calling his
name that's his brother and his brother
his has been committed he's at the
hospital so he's obviously not in the
house anymore
so he said he heard his brother though
and it sounded just like him and it
sounded like it was luring him down to
the basement and he was kind of like
laughing and stuff and he's like pretty
weirded out knowing Paul isn't there and
yet like following the voice anyway
which I would absolutely not be doing
that
um but Bobby then gets distracted by a
kind of the knock on the front door but
turns out it's just the priest that was
like a little bit of a fake it wasn't a
jump scare but it was just a little fake
out there
so they said they bring the priest in
and he listens to them and seems to
believe what they're saying is true but
then he tells them well the best thing
to do is just ignore the [ __ ] because
paying attention to the evil gives it
more power
Karen thought I don't I don't think he
knew what the [ __ ] he was talking about
because it's like if you were here and
like we experienced all this stuff like
you can't ignore the [ __ ] like how the
[ __ ] are we supposed to do that you know
what I mean because all the crazy [ __ ]
that was going on so she's like I
thought
she didn't say she thought he was full
of [ __ ] but that's what she wanted to
say like that's what I said but that's
what it sounded like
so at this point Karen remembered that a
few weeks ago she'd read an article
about guess who the Warrens
so she hadn't really thought much about
it at the time but now she's like well
I'm desperate so I'm going to call them
up and see what the what they have to
say about it
so they tell the Warrens about the
haunting and apparently at this point
they tell them like everybody in the
family has seen something or experienced
something other than the one son Mark
who I guess is like the second
youngest or whatever
um I don't know why he never saw
anything but whatever so Lorraine comes
to the house and is immediately drawn to
the basement and she called the place
she said it was horrible she said it was
a very very bad infestation so you know
what I mean of course she says it's a
demon uh and called it overwhelmingly
sickening she said also that there was a
door to hell in the basement
conveniently I mean like not literally
but there was like a portal to hell in
the basement how many houses has she
gone to and said well you got a portal
to hell how many people bottom there's a
lot there's a lot of portals yeah I
gotta hold like a Subway
got the red line
you never know when them [ __ ] are
going to open up
where's it going
Guiana
the expression yeah
it's all these different regions of hell
you can go to yeah no that's the bad
neighborhood you don't want yeah
all right so the Warrens say they kind
of they're like okay well you got a
problem here obviously uh and it's like
we gotta go approach the Catholic church
and get an exorcism of the kind of more
rare kind that's actually done on places
rather than people I guess I think they
had a name for it but I can't remember
what it was
so the Warren's call good old John
zappis who Danny Rowling brought up
before John's office is their researcher
he's also their nephew
in case you didn't know that so he's
basically supposed to go to the house
and document The Haunting so he can take
all the evidence to the church to get
permission to do the exorcism so the
research him and his research team move
into the house for a little while I
don't know how long it was and set up
all their equipment uh the Warrens also
tell them it's like it's probably a good
idea because the demon will try to like
isolate you from one another so
everybody sleep in the living room and
stay together at all times like never go
anywhere by yourself because that's
going to be a bad time
now uh the demon apparently set its
sights on the next most vulnerable
person now that Paul is out of the house
that person turns out to be Karen the
mom
so she said that um they were all in the
living room and she said that she fell
backward and then like her neck started
swelling up and her face contorted
and she said that she felt like she went
to the way she described it like I said
she's not great at describing things but
the way she described it it almost
seemed like she went
mentally like to another place and she
said like surrounded by all these kind
of like shadowy figures and got attacked
by like dark emotions all like sadness
and anger and hopelessness and yada yada
but
um so everybody's there when it happens
so they see what happens so they go at
her with the holy water into prayer and
blah blah and apparently the entity let
her go and she said that when she
returned normal she came back you know
to Consciousness or whatever they told
her that she'd been out for eight hours
although I'm guessing the implication is
she felt like it had only like been a
couple of minutes but they said it was
eight hours
uh she said that while she was out that
she realized that there was true evil in
the world and that you actually have to
choose the good otherwise the evil is
going to get you
one thing that John zaphus said on the
show because he was on the show as well
was that that all the teams mattresses
that they slept on because they had like
air mattresses and [ __ ] like and they
slipped on the living room that the
mattresses would like breathe he said
they like breathed and undulated like
and it kept the um Everybody in the team
awake like the demon was just like
[ __ ] with people I remember that
because he's a jerk yeah
it's like I'm gonna keep you awake what
it's like what an [ __ ]
um zephis also said this was the
strongest demonic possession he'd ever
experienced and as I mentioned uh the
demon liked to isolate people which is
why the team encouraged everybody to
stay together but one night John's aphis
not following his own advice apparently
went off by himself to make some notes
or check equipment or something and he
said while he was in the room it got
really really cold and he started
calling for somebody to come see him but
nobody responded and then he went into
the living room and everyone was still
asleep even though he was like yelling
for them and he said that he felt as
though whatever was gonna happen was
like meant only for him like the demon
was just like trying to keep all the
other people asleep so he opened the
basement door it looked like and he saw
the man in the suit like the demon guy
and then he sees like a burst of After
Effects fire like coming coming up from
there it feels like an explosion uh that
kind of like blew him backward
and as Danny Rowling mentioned before uh
after that he was like so terrified that
he noped out he's like nope I'm out I'm
out because he said that was the
scariest thing it's like what kind of
demon fighter are you bud
you just get one little burst of fire
and like one little sighting of a demon
and you're just like I thought you were
supposed to like be fighting the Demon
yeah there's more to that
I've seen some interviews with this guy
dug it up a long time ago he said that
it threatened him and his family if he
didn't leave that was it okay they
didn't mention that she showed him some
images of what it could do and he
doesn't want to talk about it so that he
he split another guy from his team said
that they
um
we're setting up a camera down a hallway
and as he was setting it up he saw a
phenomenon it sounded sounded kind of
legitimate he saw
what looked like a bunch of little
pieces of paper and debris start to spin
and pick up off the ground and spin into
like a little
a little
um miniature kind of like uh
like like a
dust devil you know or a little a little
miniature what do you call that tornado
like a little miniature tornado kind of
came up and it was happening in front of
an open window where light was coming in
hey sometimes in a Dusty environment you
see like the dust inside the [ __ ]
shaft of light and he could see that it
was kind of
dust and things and little pieces from
the carpeting or something [ __ ] he
could see it would blowing up into a
like a little a little tornado type
thing and it started to kind of coalesce
into a humanoid shape and then it
um I think he said he ran from it
in fear but then went right back once he
got regained his composure it was gone I
think I think that's how it ended
that was uh weird yeah they didn't
mention that on this yeah and I don't
remember if they mentioned that on the
Paranormal Witness no probably if we'd
had more time we should have watched the
Paranormal Witness episode too although
we've seen that one a bunch of times
yeah I remember that was that
investigators the guy that ran it was
his partner that saw that he was Zappos
yeah I guess it was zaphus's partner
a guy who was uh
setting up a camera a guy who was
investing yeah because he brought a
whole team there right it looked like
yeah I saw his set his testimony it was
creepy kind of plausible sounding you
know he's not saying a whole lot he's
just saying he saw a little
tornado form of little particles in that
shaft of light and it started to
coalesce into what he thought was a
person
he ran from it
uh but then like I've regained his
composure just like a second or two
after that when went around that corner
and looked at it it had dissipated
weird that is pretty weird
so yeah so zephis runs off apparently I
guess like the rest of the team stayed
there they didn't really make that clear
so uh at this point the Connecticut uh
diocese sends out another guy named
father Frank uh to see he wants to do an
investigation too to see if they'll
Grant an exorcism so maybe everybody did
leave I'm not really sure
so the family tells father Frank
everything and he took a tour around the
house but they couldn't really tell like
if he believed them or not because he
was just like stayed very stoic and [ __ ]
uh he just came in like did his little
investigation thing and wrote a report
and then submitted it but they noted the
church did actually Grant the exorcism
though so I guess he did believe them I
suppose
so then they bring in this other priest
Father Richard and he's the guy that's
going to do the exorcism now he did a
cleansing on the house which of course
provoked The Entity because that's how
it works on this show uh in the basement
like Karen I guess is following him
while he was going around doing all the
cleansing or whatever and she said that
while she was following him she saw she
didn't describe it like this but the way
she I was like I think I know what she's
talking about it seemed like something
invisible like pulled the back of his
shirt like that you know what I mean
like she saw like the the
uh material of the show yeah like come
out like that and she's like and he's
cut she said he made a face and kind of
looked but he didn't say anything
because he's one of the people like the
original priest that came in there is
like you have to pretend that it's not
happening like you're supposed to ignore
it because it gives it more power if you
get scared or whatever so you have to
like just act all like [ __ ] chill and
everything
um that's the thing and actually they
had some other like
guy um on there I can't remember what
his name was he's got he's kind of well
known because I've seen him on some
other paranormal shows but he wrote a
book called American Exorcist or
something so he was on there and he's
like saying that technically and ideally
that when an exorcist goes in your house
like to do an exorcism of your house
they're actually supposed to go in there
assuming that the act that the demon
isn't real which I thought was an
interesting thing to say but he's like
you're supposed to be coming at it from
a position of skepticism rather than
belief which I I thought that was kind
of interesting I'd never heard that
before
but I I forgot to write that down but it
was like so interesting that I just
remembered it just now when I was like
thinking about it so uh so yeah so the
priest is like trying to ignore like
whatever is happening because he knows
the Demon's trying to like provoke him
or getting get him scared and that like
gives him power or whatever
so
um there's apparently I don't know if
this is what really happened but they
heard it like a bunch of growly jazz or
whatever
and then again the priest is trying to
ignore it so then they go up into the
main part of the house and they set up
like the whole little deal with a little
uh Altar and whatnot and uh so they're
doing that and then apparently I like I
get I don't know if this really happened
or not but this is what they showed on
the show it's like a bunch of books and
[ __ ] like start falling off the shelves
all kind of crazy [ __ ] starts falling
off shelves Karen gets picked up and
thrown back against the wall and what
was actually like a pretty decent
special effect I thought well at least
what I could see like on the low res
video where she was just like and it's
like the funny thing is
has that happened and then the niece
Teresa she said she got picked up by the
neck like off the ground and was like
choking and stuff but everybody had to
pretend like that nothing was happening
so the demon wouldn't get a foothold I
guess so they just kind of had to sit
there and pretend nothing was going on
which I don't know why I thought that
was so funny but I did so um then it
kind of looked like they had Like a
Virgin Mary statue there it kind of
looked like it was melting although it
was kind of hard to tell because the
copy that we watched this on was like
[ __ ] it was on YouTube and it looked
like butt because it was just kind of
like super super low res so I'm like I'm
looking at it like that like I'm like is
it melting I can't really tell I guess
it was melting so apparently the
exorcism worked uh because they said the
whole vibe of the house changed while
the priest was praying now even though
the family believed The Entity was gone
they still decided to move out of the
house not long after the exorcism they
made it seem on the show that it's like
they as soon as the exorcism was over
they were like [ __ ] it I'm out that's
not the case they actually lived there
for another two years uh before they
moved out but on the show they made it
seem like no we just got the [ __ ] out of
there because the house had too many bad
memories and it's like we didn't want a
chance like opening the door to hell
again or whatever
now at the end of the show and like I
said this kind of made me sad but then
it's like at the end of the show they
said Paul was released from the hospital
a bit later like I said in real life it
was about a month and a half and the
program said his cancer didn't return uh
that's not what ultimately happened like
I said it didn't return for a while uh
but it did actually come back later on
like like I said he did marry and he had
three or four kids
um but the cancer did come back and he
actually died in 2012. I'm not sure how
old he was he wasn't that old I think he
was only his 40s
so um so yeah so let's kind of talk
about that was the end of the show
so let me talk a little bit about
this because I kind of feel like
they gave a lot of inconsistent accounts
like I said uh Carmen specifically and I
kind of feel like the publicity around
the case that she actually used it
because later on she went on as a career
as like a spiritual advisor she had a
you know website and everything
um she actually married again later on
so I think she goes by Carmen Reed now
or did like last I heard
and remember how I said that there was a
book written about this case back in
1992
and it was called in a dark place and
the guy that wrote it was a horror
writer and his name was Ray Garden
and he has been very public about saying
that I was hired by Ed and Lorraine
Warren to write a book about the case
but
he never went in the house
he never talked to the kid that was
supposedly you know the kid with cancer
he'd never talked to him
um and he claims that Ed Warren told him
flat out that the snedekers were crazy
and that Ray garton should just make up
details about the haunting to make the
book scarier
um because all of the stories they were
getting for all the from all the family
members were uh varied wildly
and so Ed was just like don't worry
about it just write whatever make it
scary or a horror writer basically
that's what the that's what the author
said I wrote the book about it
um and he's not shy about talking about
it either he says that they were just
all over the place huh yeah and because
well he apparently like asked Ed about
it because he was like well what the
[ __ ] am I supposed to do with all this
because all their stories are different
and Ed was just like whatever you're a
horror writer like make something up
just make it scary
now did they contradict
I'm not sure if they contradicted but it
just seemed like
like I said just they they would say
different things at different times
sometimes they would add on details that
they hadn't brought up before it's just
like all kind of [ __ ] yeah you know what
I mean I'd like to see I'd like I'd like
to have a really good interview with
that guy
yeah I wonder if he's still around
because like they didn't get him on a
show maybe yeah maybe that might be a
really interesting show yeah
because like I said he was more morning
for horror fiction really but it's like
you know they hired him for that yeah
but you're a writer too you could get
him on a show probably yeah probably
good yeah our connections we get him on
a show as I mentioned too like
Carmen uh claimed
on several occasions that she didn't
know that the house had been a mortuary
till after moving in and said that she
hadn't been able to go to the basement
before signing the lease because there
was construction ship blocking the
entrance to the basement
um but the House's owner said that is
not the case uh they said we told the
snedekers outright the house the house
used to be a funeral home well before
they moved in
um and people in the neighborhood knew
that it had been a mortuary obviously
because you know it was a mortuary they
lived there they saw it every day
um and are honestly like Carmen even in
her own statements like later she wrote
an account of the case later like on her
website and she just made this offhand
comment that her and her family knew the
home was a former mortuary but we
weren't bothered by it prior to moving
in so it's like she said before oh we
didn't know until we moved in but then
later on she said oh we knew about it
and it didn't bother us you know what I
mean so she said like two different
things
um now according to several of the
family statements the disturbances
started shortly after they'd settled
into the house and it seemed like the
early [ __ ] was like a poltergeist
infestation
um you know most of the early stuff they
reported like I said was the crosses uh
the crucifix is like disappearing off
the walls
um unexplained voices coming from empty
rooms uh and the thing about the you
know the dishes like disappearing like
she would set the table and then turn
around and the dishes were back in the
cabinet like she said that happened a
bunch and she said about the the mop
water like uh in the blood and
everything in the shower curtain and um
also the Sun the one with cancer said
that um no not the one with cancer the
younger one he actually said the lights
would flicker off and on like I said
when even the bulbs had been removed and
uh they said this house smelled really
bad all the time like a like a dead body
like Decay uh they didn't mention that
on the show
and uh basically you know
they didn't mention to you that Philip
which was the actual name of the kid
with cancer
um that he wrote about
um necrophiliac fantasies in his
notebook and like pictures and stuff
and um I mentioned this earlier but the
basement room at least as far as I could
determine was actually uh the casket
display room not the embalming room like
like they showed on the show
um but the thing about it is that
Carmen she kind of said at first she's
like well I didn't really notice any
particular paranormal activity at first
um it was only happening to the kids and
I didn't believe them which is kind of
what they showed on this show
but then like in later ones she said
that she saw stuff like weird [ __ ] like
early on so again like kind of
inconsistent
and lit and then she also said that on
some occasions she saw apparitions
herself which they absolutely did not
mention on this show uh she said that
she saw one with long black hair and
black eyes and then she saw another one
with white hair and white eyes who was
wearing a tuxedo
so they did not mention that on this
show that she said that she saw
apparitions they made it seem like the
kids just saw him and she didn't believe
it but she didn't they didn't show her
seeing any apparitions on the show but
she said that later that she did
um and basically too it just seemed like
I don't know uh so he did like Philip
did actually like attack the cousin
Tammy
so that did happen and he got taken away
for psychiatric evaluation he got
diagnosed as uh schizoph schizophrenic
and as I mentioned was hospital for
hospitalized for about a month and a
half and he did tell the doctors
apparently that uh he thought the house
was evil and was making him do terrible
things that doesn't necessarily mean the
house was haunted I mean it might mean
that he had schizophrenia and so that's
just something he was saying
um and she did say like Carmen did
mention the whole thing about the
invisible hand crawling up Tammy's shirt
and sexually assaulting her like I said
they didn't show that on the show but
that was a claim that she made all the
time
and the Warrens uh basically came in and
they said that a lot of the family
reported being like they would get
slapped all the time like by invisible
hands would slap them
and uh they were the ones because I
think Danny Rowling brought this up
before that
um the reason that this was happening is
that people that worked in the mortuary
had engaged in necrophilia there is
absolutely no evidence that that
happened
um not saying it didn't happen but
there's no evidence that it happened uh
that pretty much came from the Warrens
as far as I could determine so I don't
know if they were trying to make it more
salacious to sell more books that's kind
of where I'm at with it but uh yeah that
those allegations have not been
confirmed there's no confirmation that
anything like that was going on in there
um basically they said yeah we did the
cleansing on the house and you know
there wasn't any more activity
so as I mentioned even though on the
show it made it seem like the snedekers
were like as soon as the exorcism was
done it was successful they were like
yeah but we still moved out they
actually lived there for another two
years uh and then they moved to
Tennessee as I said Carmen is now uh
using the last name Reed and she's a
spiritual advisor uh Philip died in
2012. now the house is I believe that
the house is still owned by a woman
named Susan Trotta Smith now as far as I
know like I said I checked Zillow and
the last time the house was sold was
1998 and I'm assuming that's when she
bought it and apparently she still lives
there because no one has bought it since
then and she has been pretty vocal uh in
the media saying uh look I've lived in
this house now at this point if it's
been since 1998 it's a long funkin time
she said I've lived there uh all this
time uh and I've had no problem at all
really the only problem I have is like
now that the movie came out we get it
back in 2009 is like people like parking
on my on and taking pictures of my house
and [ __ ] like that because it's so high
profile like I said it's very very easy
to find the address of this house online
I found it in less than two minutes
and I'm sure you probably could too uh
also people that had lived in the house
prior to the snedekers also said that no
Paranormal Activity took place uh in the
house while they were staying there
either and as I said the woman that
lives there now has lived there for
several decades at this point and has
never had anything bad happen so she
doesn't really believe the [ __ ] either
so that's how that's going how do you
feel about it well my thing on that is
is that
people are taking this as a haunted
house and based on the stories I don't
even think it's an old haunted house it
sounds like Poltergeist to me so just
because she hasn't seen anything in the
house doesn't mean that it didn't happen
if it happened it happened because of
that boy
yeah and it was a manifestation out of
the coming out of him
so just because the new owners don't see
anything doesn't mean that it didn't
happen
the problem is is that the case is very
muddied
yeah uh you have to go back
to uh the earliest testimonies
and really the key would be that horror
writer he probably has access to that
he probably saw problems in the in the
story
if there were contradictions that could
be
that you know that could be a sign that
this is a hoax but
so yeah we didn't know enough I mean
everything like he never went to the
house but he did like interview the
family members and from everything that
I could determine he actually went to Ed
Warren because that's the Warren's hired
him right yeah went to Ed Warren and
said I don't know how to make this into
like a story essentially because
everything they're telling me is like
wildly deviating from one another okay
and so he didn't really know how he was
gonna do it and he said allegedly at
that point that Ed Warren said to him
we'll just make something up yeah we'll
just make it scary that's not that
doesn't mean much about the case either
because Ed would say that on a good case
well yes that's just the way he was
so maybe something did happen there uh
maybe the Witnesses were confused or
told it in a way to where it was
confusing because maybe they were
freaked out
uh maybe their imaginations went ran
wild with them so the descriptions were
[ __ ] not accurate or maybe the
timeline was I mean even I got confused
about some of the stuff that happened in
Mammoth especially over time okay
because
a lot of stuff happened so I don't
remember the exact order that certain
things happened in
so maybe maybe that's what he's talking
about I'd have to talk to that guy who
wrote that book yeah I'm not sure I mean
like that's the thing though when you
told me about Mammoth Mountain yeah and
then I talked to your aunt and uncle and
they told me about what they experienced
at Mammoth Mountain yeah there were tiny
tiny differences but not really and I
didn't really have a problem like
bringing them together because you guys
mostly said the same [ __ ] it's like
little tiny things to be different like
Oh I thought that happened like on
Saturday and you thought it happened on
Sunday but it was just like little [ __ ]
like that like the large details were
all the same I was 14 or 15 at the time
you know what I mean yeah it was and it
was a long time no you were younger than
that younger than that you were 12 or
13. 13 okay something like that I've
seen pictures of myself I'm surprisingly
full-grown looking for [ __ ] yeah I
didn't look that different at 16. but uh
the uh one of the things that I was
really astounded that I had gotten wrong
is that I thought the lamp that moved
that we saw you know or that ended up
being moved mysteriously I remembered it
being a Blue Lamp that looked like
um a bunch of logs lashed together on a
dock that had a damn life preserver
hanging off of it yeah I've seen lamps
like that yeah that's a that was what I
thought the lamp that moved looked like
the Lois and red said no no it wasn't
that lamp said that lamp was in there
but it wasn't that one it was the one
that looked like the uh a bunch of them
wax it's fun looking wet it looked like
a bunch of wax ribbon remember that oh
yeah like those candles those candles
yeah I used to have a candle like this
ribbon extruded when it was [ __ ]
melted plastic and everything and it was
like it is that's the one but see that's
not weird and I remembered it going yeah
I remember that lamp I remember that
lamp now but so I just got I got just uh
I got confused about which lamp it was
that moved but see that's not that weird
because it's like that other lamp was
actually in the place yeah it's just you
just forgot which one it was that moved
and Lois I know got some [ __ ] wrong
she said she saw the damn
twist tie from the bread
write the word go on the glass and and
no no I remember going upstairs
and finding that on the ground and it
was already written but her memory was
is that she saw it being written it did
I no I found it and it was already
written when I found it well crap man I
can't even remember [ __ ] that happened a
month ago yeah much less when I was 13.
I don't remember jack [ __ ] from when I
was 13 years old
and there was some [ __ ] that I had
forgotten all about I'd forgot all about
the Hot Wheel cars for a long time I'd
forgotten all about the knife that got
thrown out of the from the kitchen
forgot all about that and that was a
major [ __ ] incident I know I blocked
that out because that scared the [ __ ]
out of me when that [ __ ] knife went
and [ __ ]
almost hit the damn [ __ ] sliding
glass door bounced off of nothing in
midair and fell at my [ __ ] feet boom
like that and it didn't even bounce that
scared the [ __ ] out of me I almost went
unconscious and red saw it happen
and I instantly forgot about it like I
couldn't accept it yeah an hour later
I'd forgotten all about it I remember
I remember that I forgotten about it I
remember that I forgot about it because
I forced myself not to think about that
yeah well I mean is that not surprising
you were just a kid and it was really
traumatic so yeah a [ __ ] knife flying
out of that damn kitchen an empty
kitchen yeah pretty creepy yeah going
straight as a bullet like an arrow fast
weird it is weird
all right are we ready to wrap it down
I'm gonna start on that chicken yeah
he's got it yeah
yeah man it's nobody somebody early said
earlier said we should make it 13
o'clock shirt that says uh are you
hungry yet on it
wait since it's been almost two hours
but this was a good uh episode because
this is a good episode to talk about
because there's like I said there's a
lot of other information about this case
too because there's been so many
iterations of it but uh yeah so I'm glad
you guys recommended it I'm just it was
a [ __ ] to like to find and we had to
watch like a crappy version of it on
YouTube but we got it done we got it
done we watched it so uh yeah thanks
everybody for dropping by this evening
and uh tomorrow I guess we gotta watch a
movie tonight to talk about tomorrow but
I don't know which one maybe until maybe
we should watch um Time Bandits okay can
we watch Time Bandits yeah I've been
wanting to do Time Bandits for a long
time I think it's still on HBO Max I'll
check but uh because I was excited when
I saw it in there because I haven't seen
that in a long time either so maybe
we'll do that if not then we'll find
something else to do but yeah so uh
thanks everybody for dropping by today
and uh we'll see you guys again tomorrow
evening good night